a man
disguised as security or potentially a
law enforcement officer a guy
who put on a badge tried to make himself
look like an actual security
professional who was armed with multiple
Firearms was just arrested trying to
approach Robert F Kennedy Jr at a
campaign stop in Los Angeles according
to the
LAPD oh I'm sorry according to Kennedy's
team the man claimed to be part of
Kennedy's security team told RFK Jr's
actual protectors with urgency that he
needed to be taken to the candidate
immediately observing that the man had a
handgun Kennedy's security team removed
the man from the area isolated and
surrounded him then notified
LAPD uh he was spotted and detained
before this speech that's good man was
wearing two shoulder holsters with
loaded pistols spare ammunition
magazines carrying a US Marshall badge
on a lanyard and a belt clip federal ID
D and identified himself as a member of
Kennedy's team then LAPD comes in LAPD
takes custody of a second man who came
to the campaign with the first guy who
got arrested protectors observed that
that man was seeking access to the event
had a backpack and that backpack had at
least one other handgun multiple knives
and some extra ammunition good thing
that Kennedy's team bought
them Kennedy has been requesting Secret
Service
protection he's a presidential
candidate sort of a major presidential
candidate presidential candidates who
reach a significant degree of notoriety
and and profile are afforded Secret
Service protection Bobby Kennedy has not
been Joe Biden has turned down that
request even as people who sure look
like assassins show up to his campaign
events now you might say well there's
some weirdos weirdos show up to a lot of
political
events I think there should be a rule if
your father and uncle are both
assassinated while running for president
and serving as president respectively
and then you run for president I think
you automatically should be entitled to
Secret Service protection don't
you some have pointed out well a lot of
good the Secret Service did to his
father and his uncle fair
enough seems to me completely insane
that Joe Biden won't offer Secret
Service protection to a guy who's
polling 20% against him who family has
been picked off by political assassins
for 70 years doesn't that seem a little
strange I'm glad Kennedy has a good
security team and I'm all for for
shrinking government spending but I
don't know I think especially now that
you had what sure seems to be an
assassin or two show up to the Kennedy
event I'm willing for a few of my tax
dollars to go to to protect the major
presidential candidate and Democrat
threat to Joe Biden I think as we send a
hundred bazillion gazillion dollars
overseas to Vladimir zalinski to take on
the ruskies I think we can spend what's
it going to cost like a few hundred
grand to stop another Kennedy from being
assassinated seems like a good
investment to me right now go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles we all
have very busy schedules soccer practice
science fair is prepping for the
holidays Etc there good news you can
take one big thing off your plate by
putting great meat on your plate with
good ranchers you care about what your
family eats and so does good ranchers
that's why they've spent years building
relationships with local farms to Source
the best 100% American beef chicken pork
now wild caught Seafood they've added
Seafood to the mix the best of the land
and sea can now get conveniently
delivered to your door and right now
they're offering two years of free
ground beef to anyone who subscribes
that's a $480 value at a locked in price
100% American meat it's just insane no
one else is offering anything like this
and no one else is offering anything
like this at the Quality that good
ranchers brings you I adore it I eat it
multiple times a week and I would eat it
more than that if uh if I weren't
traveling quite so much so head on over
to goodranchers.com use code nolles 25
bucks off and free ground beef for two
years subscribe to any box to lock in
your price on America's best meet for
two whole years as well good
ranchers.com use code nolles for over
$500 in savings subscribe to good
ranchers American meat delivered right
now text nlls to 200 300 for most
homeowners window replacement is not
something they've done before for many
it is not something they want to do but
something they have to do if you've put
off replacing the windows in your home
because they're too expensive I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson's signature renewal service
is committed to giving you the best
customer service possible supported by
the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product I got an email from a carpenter
who told me said Michael I heard you do
a read for Renewal by Anderson I'm just
telling you I go to houses they have the
best work of any windows that I see and
coincidentally I have a cousin who works
for them and has been telling me about
Renewal by Anderson for years even
before they were on the show so right
now they're offering a free inhome or
virtual consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for 0
down zero payments and zero interest for
one year text nolles kwes to 200 300 for
your free consultation to say 375 bucks
off every window and 750 bucks off every
door these savings will not last long so
be sure to check it out by texting
nolles to 2300 that's nolles to 200 300
texting privacy policy in terms of
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text marketing messages message and data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to window appointment now.com for full
offer details do you remember a story
this was from months and months ago I
guess over a year ago that Catholic
schools in Canada had been murdering
indigenous
children how is the
story this is two years ago a tribe in
western Canada announced that they had
engaged in some ground penetrating radar
investigation and discovered anomalies
in the soil around the schools and what
were those anomalies that they suspected
were Mass Graves where these Catholics
had been educating the indigenous
children at residential schools and
immediately
all of the liberal establishment in
Canada flew into action the Prime
Minister lowered Flags to half
staff the pope issued an apology all the
way from the Vatican and then this is
the most important part of the liberal
establishment springing into
action activists started burning down
Catholic churches because don't forget
the the liberal power structure it's not
just the elected people it's not just
the media it's not just the teachers
there's also the paramilitary wing in
America that's BL M that's antifa and in
Canada you have these these activists
same same kinds of people they burned
churches all over Canada statues were
covered in graffiti statues were pulled
down Catholic statues for two years this
was going on because the Catholic
schools had been murdering all these
indigenous kids and burying them in Mass
Graves and then we turned out that
wasn't
true then we found Out oopsie Daisy yeah
none of that was true two years of
Investigations zero evidence that any of
that ever happened no Mass Graves
none now what did happen is the churches
burned
down and what did happen is the the
flags were lowered and the the statues
were pulled down and what did happen is
an actual blood Lial was committed
against Catholics in Canada by the
liberal
establishment people who were going to
those churches they don't have churches
to go to
now but oopsy days
no harm no foul moving
on 68 churches in Canada were desecrated
damaged or
destroyed and and is anyone going to be
held responsible for that no is Trudeau
Justin Castro you know the leader of
Canada is he going to
be prosecuted for spreading this Blood
liable
no any of the activists no you know what
they're going to do they're going to
move on to the next hoax and I tell you
the craziest thing is going to be
whatever the new bogus excuse is the end
result is going to be the same statues
are going to come down churches are
going to burn Traditions are going to be
upended and the liberal project is just
going to go marching
on this is the this tribal Chief Derek
nepinak they've excavated 14 locations
under the church they got nothing boy
what a great clip that was now make sure
that you subscribe ring the bell make
sure you get all the updates for the
Michael nolles Show YouTube channel see
you next time